burials in the middle of the night
this is how the city of sao paulo is
trying to cope
with the rising death toll from covet 19
in brazil's economic capital
[Music]
so far over 300 000 people have lost
their lives in brazil
more than 3 700 of them in the past
24 hours experts in the country say
brazil's need to adapt urgently to turn
the tide
brazil needs to rapidly increase the
speed of vaccination
primarily among the most vulnerable
population to stamp out speech in favor
of medicines that science do not say
are effective against covid19 and lastly
improved vigilance and tracing of the
variants that could have more aggressive
biological behavior
from the mutant strains of covid19 virus
the death toll rise comes as brazil's
putantan biomedical institute
detected a new strain of the virus
similar to the one registered in south
africa
and as president jair volsonaro
struggles to cope with sliding
popularity
and growing pressure over his handling
of the pandemic
on tuesday top commanders of the armed
forces stepped down
coming just one day after bolsonaro
replaced
six government ministers in a sudden
reshuffle that appeared designed to
secure loyalty
[Applause]
at the beginning of the pandemic
brazil's president
disregarded the risks of covet 19
and resisted taking extreme measures to
reduce the spread of the virus
we have two enemies the virus and
unemployment
it is reality we are not going to solve
this problem by staying at home
in spite of the rising death toll
bolsonaro continues to challenge medical
recommendations
this policy of isolation restriction and
curfew
with a suppression of right to come and
go goes far beyond even a state of siege
i appeal to all
authorities in brazil to review this
policy and allow the people to go to
work
the slow pace in the vaccination
campaign have people frustrated and
angry
only 2.1 percent of brazilians have
received two vaccine shots
and only one-third of the 77 million
brazilians who qualify for shots
are being vaccinated covet 19 is a major
challenge for latin america concerns are
mounting in the region because
the pandemic cannot be contained if the
crisis
in brazil lingers argentina already
suspended flights coming from brazil
and other countries like bolivia have
stepped up efforts at the border
to prevent the spread of the virus
pedestal al jazeera buenos aires